Ancient.
Sparta had its own way of speaking Greek.
They needed it for all their gruff one liners,
but history pushed them aside as a common dialect spearheaded by Athens swept
the Greek world.
Yet I'm told there are small pockets in the south of Greece where people still
cling to the old words.
The last remnant of the spartan tongue.
A school master leads his young students up the hillsides around Leonia cassette
recorders in hand.
They're on a self appointed mission to capture the words of their elders who
speak a Greek very different from the rest of Greece.
These aging villagers are among the few left who know it for him.
It used to be a quirky way of speaking at home around the table,
but now he sees in it alone,
descendant of doric crumbling into yet another Greek artifact.
Doric.
Yes,
the dialect of ancient Sparta.
Well,
Athens forge trade routes,
generated culture and spoke attic.
Sparta was busy speaking doric and grabbing all the barracks upgrades.
They said things like [inaudible] ha ha.
Mete out,
of course sputter but in Athens,
those Oz change to air hammer method Hemera or get this spot,
that spot Taz long alphas and military might couldn't stop attic from growing
into the Greek to replace all Greeks with one compromise.
It wasn't fair to ask everyone to give up all of their own words.
Why not mix the dialects a bit?
So the coin aid,
the Alec Toes,
common dialect was born.
The Hellenic world expanded and coin could be heard from Turkey to Egypt,
to Italy in Syria.
If you head down to Sparta today,
the Greek there is the same stuff you hear up.
And Athena Spartans even ended up with the Athenian pronunciation for their own
city.
Nowadays it's,
well,
it's spotty,
spotty.
So where did that Doric ah,
go an 80 kilometer drive down,
a thin parched road morphs into a twisty mountain passageway that finally leads
you to this school.
Master's quaint town of low neilia.
You'll know you've arrived when you spot these blue bilingual signs.
Proudly touting the local village or Greek on the top end.
A translation in real Greek.
One signed,
clearly spells out the languages name
Conica short and easy,
like any good Greek name.
Did you catch it?
So Go Nika,
blah,
blah.
If that left you speaking in tongues,
call it Saccone.
Ian,
this might come from the word laconic,
not as in Wid,
but as in Laconia.
The region around Sparta coincidence or is there a real ancient connection here?
Well,
we already have one way to test their spartan this.
Do they preserve that Dork Alpha where Athenian say Etha listening intently to
the children's cassettes.
One by one.
The answers turn up.
They say Mati they say I our her,
but it gets better.
The mother is Amati and the day is our mirror.
These are as exactly where Athens gives us e that's enough to raise eyebrows,
but there's another rarity.
Ancient Greek croon clothes and Sukkah once had an Ooh,
that got fronted to then your takis most sounds turning into,
he left Greece with Breanne course and sicker but Sacconi.
Ian Still keeps in old,
Ooh.
Shuko for nose.
Sukkah for figs,
but other words are unexpected.
If we're hunting for a perfectly preserved dialect,
elegant,
declensions and conjugations that stood the test of time in modern Greek get
tossed aside.
When we listen to Taccone Ian,
the fancy forms of a verb like graphical,
get off.
He's going to figure out if we make a or reduced to the poultry participle,
I get off.
Not Very Archaic.
Neither is the way they sometimes say their case.
Fig and figs are Sukkot and Sukkah,
but now insert Jay and fig and figs,
Sukkot,
chest Sukkah.
This sound change isn't even unique.
Indeed.
Hellenic linguists have a term for the extreme form of it.
See duckies most pronouncing Chen Xi as say,
and c,
but then you hear them utter a Little v.
When they say [inaudible] the sheep and of Anoxia,
the U in Greece.
Those words are supposed to start with a vowel.
Everyone does it.
Even before the Parthenon was built,
they were doing it to scholars.
The reason for this,
a barren victims as clear as it is,
tantalizing,
archaic.
Greek once had a sound woo written with a dynamic,
but it lost it.
The root one long ago evolved into [inaudible].
Not here though.
Here the sheeps and use still start with a very archaic consonant now pronounced
the pieces,
the artifacts,
the innovations fit.
This is a descendant of Doric,
but it's not frozen in time.
It's living,
it's productive.
And it's so distinct that linguists classify it as a separate language.
What would it be like if the dialect of the spartan survived and evolved on its
own until today?
Like Saccone in a country where coin A's legacy standard Greek reaches even the
most nestled towns.
So konijn struggles to keep its footing,
I guess tape recorders and uphill field trips can only do so much.
So while you once thought of Spartans as ancient warriors whose faces and voices
like buried in the ruins of this town,
perhaps with the help of Hellenic linguistics,
you can find them in the faces and voices of another town,
the last remnant of the spartan tongue.
Stick around and subscribe for language.